je me présente jus gréco vous connaissez
ma seule
extrait de mon livre j'irais cracher
leur mauvaise pub c'est ma période
glauque
voici un sketch show futuriste que
personne n'a jamais compris même pas
nous c'est la rencontre +0 de l'infini
je serai le zéro comme d'habitude et
jean marc thibault le comédien qui
souffle
sur le mail repos de la guerrière sais
pas pourquoi d'ailleurs saisi
et bien c'est récent
sera logique war 3 et moi tu le zéro et
moi je suis l'infini je veux mon chemin
son frein son feu sont fois il ne veut
pas nous est méritée moyen terme c'est
normal machines à sous comme machin rage
le savez toutes les hyperboles me
cherches tu as lu ça toi quand les
paraboles je connais une môme qui dix
ans elle appelait lui vint encore une
parallélépipède qui donne dans le carré
de l'hypoténuse à pomas et molécules
absurde
d'abord on n'est pas branché sur le même
secteur mais c'est vrai je n'ai pas mes
quatre cinquièmes d'azoté imprudent
sortir sans attente
mais si la bonne impression et par
conséquent et vous emporte et toi as-tu
avellin gaulier oui trente trois 33 33
tromper que fait que j'écoute mon
turquie pauvres ce soir j'ai transfusion
amoureux aux veinards son genre son nom
diesel 400 chevaux un vécu énorme
machine elle a dit mon corps et d'une
turbine et mon rêve c'est une belle
paire de cuers
mais quitte à pistonner pour avoir sa
belle étranger tu veux savoir
oui c'est pi 3 416 pire toujours les
glisseurs pourquoi vesta ligne d'horizon
et de monstres est loin seul nom a de
plus beau de plus deux à ces qualifs
sicile à audrey apporte des casse croûte
à mon nom puisque tout corps plongé dans
le jeu nous reçoit dans 20 ans ou une
poussée mais toi tu es l'archivé
architectes travaillent 23 ans
téléphones sous android et ulm d'amour à
l'eau par principe
et alors mais celle appliquée comme tu
dois souffrir par les nuits sans lune
surtout à maubeuge
je me rapproche de traitement va se
confond à ce fonds on sera bientôt plus
qu'à un point
fiat a voulu partir vivre mais pour nous
ça ça mais avec